o o o say it again o o it became like a
big Trend in The Stunt World JJ Perry
who's now he was a director of dayshift
this Texan who came into the Taekwondo
World from the Army really good in the
80s at Taekwondo in the stunt Community
as a morale booster he'd go stunt set we
go us all the way to like John Wick four
you know when the Japanese guys face all
the tall basketball players the
basketball players weren't stunt guys
they were just locals we found first
take they had zero energy went up to
them and I was like you see those
Japanese Guys these little think
they're really going to win this
war and they're like huh I go look at
them and the they're like
hey like we need some energy when I say
stun set I want everybody to go US
during the take I go stud set all the
like 7 foot basketball players oh and
the Japanese guys were like
oh oh